here's the reality on [ __ ] off Monday
now here's the reality there is they
were seeing we're seeing uh seeing
somebody so hot I said if she had AIDS
out there are women I want to start this
by saying there are women who if they
had said to you I have coronavirus or e
AIDS
ah don't [ __ ] me there are women that
guys would say I'm taking my chances
I'd say 14 days of a tummyache sign me
up yeah I mean that would cut off a
finger for her there are there are those
women out there cut my [ __ ] finger if
I want to show my dedication to her down
well there are women that you give a
pinkie now you'd give the first knock
first no no not the whole pinkie right
no I'll do whole pinky cuz I don't
really need how to do that mean that's a
lot that's a lot of that what for
hurting for her
I'll do the ah take get her off get her
off for the kids she's a married woman
with a kid those are small details all
right here's why you can't use you can't
take this finger to you know a turtle we
need that for shooting they don't injure
turtles do it we just went shooting you
know that you don't need your pinkie you
need that you need your ring finger your
middle finger your index finger and your
thumb you gotta have the Robocop it up
because when I'm doing my tactical
shooting I need I don't need my pension
hit my video me being [ __ ] John thick
so funny
John fake was the brightest I was
laughing so hard that watch this I was a
video foul that a myth
surely stem by hit hit hit hit hit [ __ ]
on the ground pop ow yeah they have that
little kick down it's action I kid it's
a small person let's get it let's get it
correct that boom shake it daddy shady
show so cold
there was laughing at that look at that
dude
now that's a very expensive that's an
ar-15 the one they used in John wick I
guess that's what they tell me
daddy's trying to shoot them they did
some shooting at a place called Tarrant
tactical and Boyd ten doesn't mess
around
now how about I guess he was the best in
the world for nine years ten years he
said yeah like he they did but three
guns shooting with his pistol tactical
shotgun ar-15 correct me if I'm wrong
once you start doing that me Rogan and
you were out there and and you get kind
of addicted to the speed of it I was
trying to [ __ ] hit those chi-ching
chi-ching I was inpatient oh and daddy
just wants to blast away like I'm Isis
if you don't like you don't like going
through the reload the draw all that
stuff is very boring you just want to
get it give me the yeah you know when
you left I worked the assault rifle and
a little um battalion I know that's what
I was looking for the guy heard of my
fir it daddy's gonna buy that for that
daddy's accurate burglars
burglar from me I got my tactical
shotgun and I'm very my daddy's gonna
light him up like it's zero dark thirty
I got my custom outfitted Glock yeah but
he showed us that that assault rifle
he's gonna build for us hmm
finding the kid assault rifle yeah one
for the fighter one for the kids right
well it's very important they sorry for
them already I want to be [ __ ] red D
you know that was fun I'm addicted
there's a lot that goes on there's a lot
that goes on to shooting there's a lot
that goes on he's saying most people
when they go to holster the gun is
shooting shows what do you we share who
works there Plex go Barris it yes and
her son came first the bullet the bullet
bunnies are heavy around them yeah
they're heavy thumpers yeah and I'm
heavy supper pushers I was trying to
with Alisha she was pulling drawing and
I was trying to draw on straw that's
what do they do
she was beating me by a full sack I was
watching it was driving I kept looking
over go a [ __ ] second then they have
guns where you can use lasers now what I
do daddy me and Taryn would laugh at you
know this right behind your back yeah
cuz I was trying to do it second the
second day my second time shooting now
shoot when my eyes open and I was
actually pretty damn well I go back no
decimals daddy goes look pence I think
who's that
Rossiter plate or no that's broke pants
I think yep
I'm very happy with the way she shoot
I'm not mad at it oh [ __ ]
she's a shoe shoe shape this is Brooke
ence Brooke pence Brooke she's like a
fan crossfitter the other name wrong but
what is it pen sense there's no pee oh
damn she's super buff oh yeah dear god
she's odd she's in take it to shred Vale
yeah take the shred bill um well you
want it you want to you want to stay
hard and you want your guns ready yes
tactical shotgun is next I want to do
that I'd like to shot old what'd he say
we're going back this week yeah and then
he's getting one of those those live her
body's ridiculous yeah one of those live
way shredded one of those live dummies
that let she look like a person and when
he shoot it shows the blood splatter
memory shows the video he's like this
why won't you guys just like $5,000 a
doll oh yeah now it's $2,000 mm so it's
an actual show um it's on Amy where they
cut in they like build old-school
weapons and they cut into the the the
doll yeah kinda yeah it's got blood it's
got force oh my god it's as close as you
can get to a human body I found that to
be that bit disturbing you and I both
are see when you're shooting guns in
that environment and then you see video
of a dummy that looks like a human body
with blood in it gets shot and then I
reminded you of that guy who got his
face chewed off by the grizzly bear both
of our backs got really tight yeah my
back gets tight I whenever I'm at a
shooting range Egyptian I can assure you
that's it I guess super my actual real
tight my back daddy's back that tight
yeah daddy's back I don't like violence
like that when you see what what those
bullets can actually well he goes this
what it looks like he took a
nine-millimeter shot in the head and it
just shows all the blood yeah it was at
some kind of a special how about me and
Rodell can you imagine shooting actual
human run ghosts sure can yeah sure can
uh though
yep what well if he goes that burger
that came in your house at one time you
would have shot him the faith right
FairPoint I was talking to a seal Hood
SEAL team DEVGRU guys he tell you to
wear socks no he'd been no I'm cool he'd
been um he'd done a lot of action you
know he's a seeing some stuff he's yeah
soul snatcher and he I said I said to
him I said when you get when you shoot
somebody a lot of times like with a like
an ar-15 is gonna do some serious damage
but like a pistol and stuff people it's
not like you should pop up and he just
Falls sometimes you going they keep
going to pull their gun and shoot you
too
so you got to be you got to be shooting
for center mass I double tap bop bop
center mass head oh I do uh tell you
Walking Dead only I had shots on only
had solid shot by the way you were
shooting dicks and heads he was on
riders and Brendan was shooting Dixon
heads and Taran was like you're hitting
you're hitting him in the dick and now
you're hit him in the head can you go
center-mass please
and Brendan was like nope you aim high
game high yeah I'm I'm gonna be brave
now I'm gonna be yeah bro how many well
I watched a movie and the guy was
holding the gun and I was like okay dude
write your own the gun wrong okay yeah
like I was watching taken last night
just the end of CEO help gun yes like
it's your thumb bro were your thumb so
you need a lot of shoot guns since I was
a little kid really yeah my dad taught
me
oh [ __ ] well you're Korean they're
[ __ ] hardcore and he was military as
a Marine so he was a gun collector -
he's like Korean Marines are no joke
your dad's no joke a buddies are riot
yeah so you dad taught you how to shoot
you how to take apart put together clean
shoot Wow make you recite stuff like
this is my gun this is only my gun no
great without this guy and I am NOT
stuff [ __ ] don't don't [ __ ] you're
not gonna push cheering he's not gonna
fall over
cuz he's not a pushover I'm not a
pushover understand me I'm gonna
challenge chin tell him his audience
yeah we got cat who comes and spit me
you're [ __ ] through Vietnam the only
country that has never actually ever
been caught ever been conquered let me
know I mean it was colonized for a short
time there like the Afghanis they're
like
let you say stay here for a second but
by the way never forget we're Fiat nummy
so get the [ __ ] out of here mm-hmm and
you're gonna fight him and they'll
[ __ ] build tunnels underground yeah
yeah they've got a [ __ ] hands full of
rice yeah and you know what Maya this
guy who's a marine in Vietnam finger in
life in Vietnam said he was that marine
he had frag all over here shrapnel all
of his legs Geoffrey amazing guy who
took us through Afghanistan a fake Recon
Marine he said that Viet Cong they were
all headshots man they just you they
were such good shots headshots don't
[ __ ] with the Koreans of the Vietnamese
no reason to though either you no reason
to I don't your reason to have your
forest yeah George uncle a friend of
mine a friend of ours enjoy your jungle
and bugs a friend of ours who's a who's
done some drug-dealing
you and I know he said he said to me he
goes there were there some guys and I
said well those guys and he said I just
guys you know I said they look
interesting he goes he goes whenever you
see an Asian guy whenever you see a
Vietnamese guy with traps he's probably
a criminal that's very accurate very
accurate right yeah guys have [ __ ]
traps because yeah usually that's a
criminal cat how you holding up in the
quarantine all right I'm going a little
I have a slight cabin fever me too this
is my thing tell me if I'm wrong wrong
on this I don't think America especially
is gonna quarantine much longer I think
they're gonna say [ __ ] this if he goes
past April 30th I don't think people are
gonna put up with a frank grillo as bike
people okay people are gonna look at the
stats and go I'm gonna rescue me I don't
have any underlying conditions I'm gonna
take yeah well Frank Grillo was biking
in Venice with his two sons and he goes
to Venice was packed
dude I went to Farmers Market in
Calabasas packed haha I know well the
thing is that there was this New York
Times report I told you who's obviously
a communist and I'm being serious and a
lot of guy was calling for our one-year
shutdown and this [ __ ] so whenever you
hear people say this like these words
from the New York Times which is as left
as it gets
I'm telling you right now this is a
reporter he's also in an MD he's a he's
the enemy he's a guy who's never made it
so he wants it he wants to shut
and he was 100% unemployment because
because what he wants he says he's
trying to save lives what what a piece
of [ __ ] like this wants actually is for
the government for our economic system
to crumble and for like so what happens
the government the federal government
has to come in and pay all save every
what's called communism you know - you
wanna take that guy you know he was
commies gonna kick you you pissed down
their throats yeah well you just march
on it's damn life
your marginalize them you piss on them
you just know what they're doing just be
aware of what the [ __ ] they're trying to
do I'm not saying that this this is a
this virus you know obviously all right
you know they made a good point on Chuck
Scarborough I think I said said look a
lot of these old people are our veterans
our Korean War our Vietnamese via
Vietnam War veterans these are our
veterans they're older people our
parents our grandparents gotta pay to
protect them of course we do a hundred
percent
oh and just mainly how about that doctor
was on this one did you eat this yeah
thing I sent you the doctor on the front
lines you become a little bit alike yet
he probably keeps telling me stuff I did
a lot to maintain this with my sister
sent and then I said then I do you know
what I do because I'm flat fault I send
you the screen shot the most important
stuff and that's not a little waste your
time well I said just watch the
beginning cuz this guy was at the cove
in 1907 and he's in New York Hospital in
I think Cedar sinai which is the premier
hospital in the world they do heart
transplants lung transplant same here
and he said it's becoming a Cove in
nineteen hospital I think it's Cedar
sinai but it's that become the cove in
1907 the front lines
he's the specialist and he said we're
learning more and more about this
disease he said at the end of the day
you're gonna catch it if you if you
shake hands with somebody who has it or
you touch a surface that was just
touched by somebody and then you touch
your face be a hand Nazi Purell don't
touch your face don't touch your
something not sue but how about the fact
that it can live on what plastic and
metal for three days and cardboard for
one hour
wash your hands don't touch your face
wash your hands don't touch your face
wash your hands don't touch your face
and don't spit when you talk cuz you do
I have taken it out here spit you got
very close I spit into his face
yesterday an accident when I was talking
I don't know it felt like I did you were
just telling me and stretching on it
like this I saw some special lips
Korona yeah maybe did you add you might
have had it didn't you get sick oh dude
oh my god did I get sick you did I tell
you know what I'm sick of I'm sick of
the tiger king I'm over it now because
we found out he doesn't really make his
music the complete [ __ ] lying what do
you mean he hired someone to make his
music yeah but he sings no listen I his
voice he hired a guy I know it's why
they came out like that's our music no
we wrote in saying he just dubbed his
mom he's such a [ __ ] bad guy
oh my god he's such a piece inside
another three years that 20-year
sentence for being a piece of [ __ ]
that's hilarious I thought he had a
great oh my god man I thought he had a
great voice nope
that's fantastic they'll be and give you
a hell of a deal on the tiger that I can
vouch one I give you a good deal um but
I'm sick of Tiger King now I'm sick of
Joe exotic and I'm [ __ ] sick of
talking about Corona and I know the fans
act I hear you didn't [ __ ] around we
have dr. Drew on Wednesday sewing a
pretty ball steeped in cronic cuz he
knows his [ __ ] yep doctor you stalked
her dr. Weir bro he's gonna come in with
a [ __ ] mask I wonder no no he's more
on the loosey-goosey side no he doesn't
he live your life this is typical it's a
heightened sense of the flu Eenie live
your life and go about your business we
shouldn't be shutting the economy down
exactly and that's why I haven't been
mom well we'll see I kind of I don't I
think he's like that you know I don't
know he might get him like why are we
here and why don't you guys in masks
well say and then we hold him down like
his face you hold him down you like his
face
truce lookin buff hmm drew of the doc
what's he what's he tweeting huh
he's pretty positive though no kidding
it's gonna have a guy like that though
hell yeah it is
hell yeah listen the media man [ __ ] I
don't know I hear people watched I
wasn't calling for our one-year
shuttling you [ __ ] you know that will
happen when economy shut up a lot more
people would die then a lot more people
would die
telling you ain't quarantine Americans
man for longer than this April 30th
that's what even today the road was a
little busy on April 30th do you have a
good sense of how people how Americans
behave you're you're pretty good at that
you're pretty good at that so uh that's
my guess
nacho in this quarantine you realize you
sure you wanna be stuck in that person
for an island for life and rarely get
sick on an island with one person who
will it be
you sure my kids at home my kids are
going structure crazy eight and eleven
year old like my son time fun cuz he's
four you know Mike I know my son asked
today he goes pop I won't see my friends
my toes about the sickness boy well
they're doing a whole bunch of my kids
are doing zooms gay though you know yeah
I know I know I know
this woman whose grandparents not none
of them they they're really social so
what they do is they mean in their golf
carts in their retirement home and they
all meet no he's allowed to get out of
the car call girl up yeah but they
circle up and they just drink and talk
that's cool it's great you got an
innovative an you gotta innovate
[ __ ] dude I'm good with this
with three guys you're not going through
yeah did you say I know you try and
press those girls pop let's get a little
they were impressing me like
testosterone they were like how old he
is 35 and I was like come on girls Papa
[ __ ] up took his Porsche and I didn't
know this was a hidden gun range and had
to [ __ ] off-road in my Porsche it's
in its rough yeah
Keanu Reeves was that Bryant oh dude
that's if we finally released
you can play chimp we finally reached
the wild west CBD commercial there you
go
we can play for fans right Jen yes sure
I want the released outtakes of us
laughing and you doing it yeah walk
they're going this idea go dude you're
gonna love this you look young about the
CBD industries like the Wild West you
never know what you're gonna get
I represent pure spectrum you know
exactly that you're gonna get so I ride
into this lawless like old country town
right now I'm representing irrespective
on the sheriff and I'm all of them big
burly horses I like a brown horse and I
and then all the townsmen they circle
around me they just all gathered because
they represent the other CBD they don't
want me in there okay they're found real
oh they're bad guys I'm good guy their
guns I'm good guy they have guns and
they take them out and I hear one go hey
stick cowboy we don't want you coming
around here this is that mount of fact
now and he goes get on out of here and I
go cuz they don't want pure spectrum in
the market why would they fly with them
and then all make your move boy and then
I see one girl come out of the bar she's
like don't
and I'm like sweetie Bob take it from
here and they draw their guns I'm like
oh we're doing this not up in here y'all
they're just all laid out so sick man I
think it's slow motion as a wild horse
right like I'm going and there's like
smoke and the town's blown up behind me
like this
and then my horses aren't the innocent
people there no they ran during the few
in the swing go oh that's a thick ass
cowboy how are you riot sweetie I know
what the town's
the tell Paige and then in slow motion
it's like and then I'm looking like
super smoky and then even my horses slow
motion goes and I look at the camera
pure CBD in this town and it's pure
spectrum partner you do I knew it
this makes me want to use pure spectrum
you know what do you think the left - is
it too much
No oh yeah oh yeah it was the thing this
the magic with Brian count
there was no script for that we did that
on the spot if we did it on us to do
that on the spot on the spot it was all
on the spot yep Brian got throw here's
what I'm thinking Brian goes try this
and then we'd go through it and then we
did we have so many outtakes and mean
just me and him switching it up yeah
because I wanted to have just those
women kind of setting them up and they
did a great job
they're great out of the way yeah yeah
there's no script for that the street we
work well together
yeah the best we need to start shows on
specs left so I want I want to start
doing some more commercials I know I
dude I keep telling you but you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I keep want to do uh finally
kid 3d - people are asking orders
I keep telling big dope sketch is dead
we got appeal no I dad that's what Sasso
said but I think I never built an
audience man I'd [ __ ] Rock I know I
wanna rock all right what do you know
cuz you're quarantined I'm going through
my phone and I posted this lunch in the
old school if you go to finally kid
YouTube the briefs who had people forget
we were the first ones to do this and
everybody in their [ __ ] lesbian aunt
are doing it animation there we hide
polytune I don't know six years ago yeah
and we did the bust one do you remember
this story he'll go if you go to go to
play oh yeah that was good Regulus with
the Porsche yeah yeah and then go to its
hungry hippo yes once I bought some Russ
Hungry Hippos can have a movie based off
a board game what are you picking well
Hungry Hungry Hippos butts a [ __ ]
fantastic Hall genre choice dance
Oh stupid it's a horse there are to be
her terrifying hippo cannibals I have to
begin to make based off a true story and
a board game
it's Hungry Hungry Hippos starring Bryan
Callen yeah I want to be a hungry hippo
you're the badass you're the Chris Pratt
character yes like lost worlds perhaps a
little better-looking and taller than I
am
you're the cast you yeah at the gig [ __ ]
yeah I the meter I'm gonna be the voice
of the bird that cleans their mouth yes
it's great
who is that clean is that like a boy so
you're the person that you're the star
and I'm finally in the water where I get
the light dropping guys grab so what you
voice my voice is I'm a hero so I gotta
yeah yeah I'm the brains of the
operation hippler hippos stupid I'm ki
kind of organized I'm like it's not very
good a voice this I don't do impressions
can I be an ageing super Y offensive
really no no sir we're not we're you
can't I'm an agent rajala typical
offensive Asian impression that that was
around in the 60s to be clear it doesn't
mean that asian crocodiles speak Chinese
speaks English he says a little Chinese
playing so give you for all the career
that's I say make a widow just like kill
the guys before I send the hippos on we
are all to go with the same licorice you
don't say make a wish apologize officer
by the Klan
funded crosses everywhere
brought to you by white supremacy watch
another one go to the Yoda what else we
get all right we should do these again
huh should be a higher quality again
it's a great crime because I mean Rogan
were posting the ones from the [ __ ]
uh about to bust they take a while
though well I never thought I would see
the day it's for you big brown got well
almost got in a fight so we were piled
in my porch at the time which I had
having that red Porsche so I get off on
the exit I mean I'm sitting there joke
and whenever to bullshitting and I see
this guy yelling like furious I'm like
look at that guy be with the yelling at
and then Brian is uh I think talking to
you so roll down the window like what's
up man
and he's you cut me off you son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you mom like what the hell so
I'm like whatever I roll up the window
homeboy gets out of the car yeah
first he slaps the piss out of my car
slap snitch slaps his car [ __ ] slap
[ __ ] slaps his red Porsche hard
oh no oh hell no and then as he makes it
his way over to my car door he kicks the
car and then I get out of the car calm
calm calm
cuz you don't to escalate the situation
so he's yelling at me and he's getting
closer he's getting louder no what are
you gonna do then we get old nose to
nose and I think that he kind of went
this guy's big but he's got to be a
[ __ ] gets in your face not notes notes
could you shorter but thick so he was
more on nose to chin on you but you know
like you sucked on his nose
you could have sucked his nose no matter
what you say the face thing in the world
you said sir
you're pushing up against my bubble oh
good and I'm about to bust parties
Brides in the car this whole time about
doing
he rolls down the window sticks his head
out and goes you turn around he got in
his car and I read like three workers I
see they're his kids and they were older
like 18 20 at least I just point out the
three kids went and stayed in school I
got back in the car we took off we just
took off yeah I'm embarrassed shout out
to that guy so much fun dude
goddamn there's one more chin we can
play these cuz we own them right hell
yeah
give us like Ultimate Fighter you know
when your guys are doing that
they'd even show this on the air so she
this guy I'm liking mentions name on the
show he lost you need your drink all
that alcohol you want in the house and
there's only at the time there's only
four of us left still stories Jones six
you hit reown myself that's the four
fighting right so are you guys
one of the other guys is hammered
hammered wasted all of a sudden this guy
gets super racist in the house and
there's a bunch of black guys in the
house starts throwing up racial slurs
and throwing up these you know the hit
hey Hitler stuff I'll Hitler's write his
name on this piece of paper all right
what'd he do with the paper biggest
fight of my life the next day and I
thought it was a dream Kimbo Slice and
Marcus Jones and this D'Amico and the
stucco Rogers comes in my room they go
yo shop Get Up dawg
get up man I'm like oh three large black
guys around my bed Kim goes yo man this
dude's down there talking about our
people we're about to Jack him up
I look at thousand Jimmy oh excuse me
it's talking about our people dawg let's
go F this dude up and like listen uh you
guys realize I said I'm down the race
thing but you realize I'm not black
right kudos you ain't black nobody goes
damn that's crazy turn around leave and
I hear that's what lights job you can't
tell what the hell he is
and I go hey Kimbo that's racist values
why oh just cuz I'm athletic can fire
y'all be black yours you could be such a
great stir wow that's interesting man
yeah why did they [ __ ] those guys up
that would defy tansu or now
no no they took care of them yeah I just
staff have to get them out of there you
know
yeah that's kind you know well it's cool
story that's like hey dude what are you
in the seventies sixties yeah I don't
you're just hammered and you know I
don't know you know it's pretty dealing
with some other [ __ ] cartoons of so
old-school their old skills forever ago
huh I know it really does
back when the world was you know when
you can congregate hey Brian big news
your Texan DM and people but we should
be worried about your teeth straighten
your teeth are so much easier than ass
man I'm talking candid clear aligners
you could be one of these guys they
deliver clear aligners directly to you
and straighten your teeth for 65 percent
less than brazen celebration I know
these are their comfortable
removable and totally invisible don't go
set don't set a foot in a doctor's
office waiting room your treatment is
prescribed remotely by licensed
orthodontist and candid delivers
everything you need right to your door I
definitely do it
these people are active movement alright
and it half treatment length is six
months what seeing results way before
that yes learn about Canada's process
and get a complimentary see 3d scan of
your teeth at a candid studio near you
it is the simplest freest way to get
started so are you guys ready for
straight teeth cool for a limited time
get started with $75 off by using the
code fighter at can decode calm slash
fighter that's can decode calm slash
fighter use code fighter for $75 off can
decode concise fighter code fighter
straight teeth when you could I saw some
post all right he said all I look
forward to is when I sit down to the
rest right here can I start you guys off
with some apps it's all looking so [ __ ]
you only didn't get me through that's so
true dude yeah
going out to dinner on the bus going out
to dinner is great just pick up food now
[ __ ] you just pick up food but there's
something about going to a restaurant
like a good one
there's this great restaurant in
Manhattan Beach called [ __ ] post the
post the post it's so good nice it's so
good oh that's so [ __ ] good they got
these they got these bacon biscuits yeah
man Beach Post they have a little
biscuits they got these these cheddar
biscuits just sick yeah you know
everything about them is everything
about that place is great you don't do
that cuz you're carnivore but god I
cheat on my diet yesterday got to do it
right don't do that 10-speed coffee
uh-huh and I'm sitting there I'm looking
at the menu and it says breakfast tacos
I'm like breakfast tacos this can't be
any good and then they they smoke their
oh I know that I know after a whole
brisket yep and they put eggs with a
little bit of cheese and then their
housemates also with the house-made
tortilla is that [ __ ] that's that's not
even that's not ten people but well that
stents penis is attached to the
restaurant yes
yeah and that restaurants called fork
and yes something like not two forks or
something like once in a man like that
up in breakfast sandwiches stupid oh
dude it's crazy Stu I get my coffee and
I had to try those yeah yeah if you
click on it though on the map it's a
peddlers fork peddlers for Hitler's fork
peddlers for sales to go out in tents be
copper connect I used to go there all
the time
do I go every day yeah I've been there
every day nice coffee great coffee the
bay a heavy black car I want one now
those are it yeah what's up Papa
ten-speed baby it's great food man
honestly dude I'm gonna start those are
just the regular tacos that see some
celebrities up in that [ __ ] to some
celebrity I'm there anymore
all right yeah that make take care yeah
we're looking dangerous in with your
guns all thanks John thick I'm coming
back but also that tends to be copy Nam
always on my foot you had tightening
calories from itching is that what
you doing trying to see I just see what
they look like but you know I'm always
on that peloton how do you need to get a
real bike daddy hates a real but you do
now you ever the hike or they close that
down
you can't stop daddy for my stuff no I
have all sorts of trails I don't know
anybody okay do I go hiking with my son
every day help me up I need to go okay
you can come with us all right it's
right behind my head like that we go
every day and we were two days ago nice
hi guys come on it looks like it's a
beast yeah I'd like to do that we go
every day and the other day my son has
had tons of energy so he was like run
papa run so I was running downhill grown
man know how to control myself going
downhill
well he's four he does it and so he's
running laughing and I see him and we
had our shirts off trying to got a I
take my shirt off he wants his sure
enough so both had our shirts off oh
dude faceplant body
cry he started crying a puppet you're
fine you're fine when I tell me fine
he's like and he pops up and he just has
Wolverine so it was just like surface
scratches because it got daddy says he's
got daddy sturdiness yeah he's fine he's
got it he's got so the only
four-year-old I've ever seen with traps
yes generally he's genuinely got traps
and the biggest hands big hands big feet
you're working with a beast when he runs
yes and when he's when he brought he has
really good for me to run this guy on
the trail goes Jesus what are you
feeding that kid yeah I'm like macaroni
Nikon cheese pizza he's got a goal of
cookies called genetics every morning
asks me for a cookie that's samoan you
got a you got a half Mexican yeah baby
Simone yeah you got a baby smile I don't
think I post do you have other picture I
post a list from fine kid 3d great
I remember you hey my favorite is when
these [ __ ] morons DME go dude
quarantine really and you guys are doing
this Mike you [ __ ] idiots
this white you know you have thin out
the herd okay nothing hopefully you grow
yes turn out the earth it's just
actually incredible my makeup work is
good I know we have real-deal people
that's so good that was the best sketch
we did in a way that acting and said
that was good that one was good that one
was good and the one
going for the audition as the police
officer oh my god you're hard though
we're so good not remember that you were
so girl fun that was she was so good and
that those very good acting dude very
good acting because you weren't acting
no we never had all the one with wills
really good - oh we can't kill him
faster well how about the one with you
how about when we kill your wife
oh yeah dude I like naked and afraid
that's a great one - they were all me
and Brian were butt-naked we kind of
should probably and Mitch was a huge
part of that ministry you well we do is
have Mitch on board son now hundred
percent we have Mitch we have Marshall I
know we have Dahlia involved I I'm down
dude did you I'm down I tried to get us
all together and you just didn't want to
do it who didn't do it you dude I've
been forcing you to do it afraid
I think Fox owns them right but I'm sure
they're all over [ __ ] we all have to see
them no no weed remember we played in
last time we gotta yeah so you can buy
them right can you still buy them I
think you still get it on a platform
called voodoo what happens if we kept
find the kids 3d what's that I mean we
saw them on Vimeo they're free on Vimeo
really yeah you can if you Google we can
find him but we can't play him on here
now cuz we got Flag last time I haven't
seen forever Oh remember when I need
life insurance because I might die oh my
god yeah and we went through the
speed-dating yes and then you like I got
and that's when he kill me trying to
find your replacement there it is dude
that was so [ __ ] fun we were laughing
so hard at that I came with that shirt
that's my badass shirt yeah I mean that
sick yeah isn't that [ __ ] sick so if
you got finally kid 3d the VIP package
came with that shirt and all the series
and Brian special dude we we sold a [ __ ]
have you ever seen how many of those we
sold right cuz I was talking to Luis he
owns mouth guy go dude me and Brown
wanna do a fine kid 3d part deuce and he
was wearing a hundred cent on board let
me know what you guys want to do damn
get a one made remember that we should
do it it was so fun I think I feel like
well there right now is when we should
write it
we're all scared ah that was fun man it
was just fun - yeah was and and the beat
I'll go back chin because I saw uh honor
this this is all remember therapy don't
go to the where did I just see that at
this one who's not venmo is that what
you say Vimeo Vimeo Vimeo I saw it
somewhere scroll down
mm-hmm oh there it is Mitch rouse venmo
oh say no to drugs PSA the mast and if
you click on that would go to jail
I probably owe to that Vimeo really yeah
see I think it's that whoever the
director was I think it's his uploads
that was four years ago
well we can't play this on that I just
so you know even though Mitch posted it
yeah unless you can contact him and see
if Mitch's are done I think we tried
last time by something that's way we did
for old time's sakes play for me cat or
what am i terrible sorry this is the
funny part where we jump in the ocean
have you seen these guys yeah god damn
dude I think that's so we did that in a
day that's crazy
Oh none of them took long today and we
wrote me Mitch and Brennan wrote all's
Lewton we met at the pally house I think
we should I think we all said you know
what I think you know what I think we do
I'm being seriously I think you me and
Mitch sit down we just replicated so I
think we do eight of them fine but we
didn't say about writing but we just
need this rib I agree we sit down and
start writing yeah and we just and we
just write eight and I'm well let's do
it Beth do it we'll do it zoom if Mitch
doesn't wanna you know whatever the case
let's start doing it we can do it from
our allegory two hours a day we'd knock
it out that was so good and then we have
marker to do it all and we just cast out
there's a big dude we cast it with my
buddy so you get one we get one lead
sponsor so
covers the bills Wow we involve chin and
cat 100% fun man 100% he can act you
you've studied acting too right I want
this girl for theater dude come on
this would be sick sick I tried doing it
you're like yeah I think sketch is dead
no I'm a hundred percent down that's
sketchy dude no that's like that's great
stuff so funny that's crazy I used to
watch that in college when I first found
you guys I found you guys room into one
of these clips yeah that's how I started
listening to the podcast I wonder I
think what you get a sketchy along for
that oh yeah I do I wonder if we can we
I wonder cuz what if they talk to who
sell them that's great talk to Feldman
and talk to we stuck him it's moot
Justin how deceive someone about that
when I talk of Josh Lieberman two or
three words I know Josh really well me
too he's my man they would they can as
he watched it I see my thing is is we
did those like five years ago
people like you know Fox kind of hoarded
so people get josh homme please get Josh
on this so since that guy Mitch posted
this on his Vimeo he has the rights to
do this I wonder if you just went
through him to see how you can post
these things I'm sure he knows it's 13
minutes long they were amazing anyone
down we did we did and let me see the
trailer there's only a minute let me see
this one with the dog the fake dog very
good dude those are funny very good
all right it's a bummer Pam can't see
them I know if I don't get 3d watch it
yeah let's do some current events oh oh
this close are you guys taking any
precautions huh
being careful I'm trying but then
at the day I'm like I always end up
touching my face me too
always try to like I always end up
touching my face I hate it too my eyes
yeah stuff is to die stick my fingers in
my mouth that's about day oh yeah all
the time
alright now that's this is the first one
okay so this was sent in from Christian
Cassini and apparently the T fat K Bobby
Lee molesting the story is going viral
on tick-tock it has 17 million views o
1.7 but 1.7 million likes what enough
[ __ ] somebody uploaded it onto tik tok
and I was just going viral really yeah
let me see it that's the thing we can't
access it yeah for some reason I
couldn't I was just Bobby telling us
about him get blasted me and Brian up
trying out that exact same the guy was
he's so [ __ ] funny so funny cuz he
kept making kept exaggerated making it
worse every time yeah he kept making
worse he knew what he was doing he was
torturing so funny I don't remember I
remember us laughing I'm rest trying I
was laughing saying I'm slapped - I
think right no not that time that was
last time he came he hit me with a shoe
my knee and it really hurt it [ __ ]
hurt I love Bobby he's the greatest he's
so fun to get us with the young kids
yep tick tock what else you got this was
submitted by Angie Willy on Instagram
apparently over in India police officers
are taking it upon themselves to have
more creative punishments for people who
are breaking their routine roving bands
of of police officers in India so there
are police officers who are physically
beating people who are on the streets
unnecessarily and then there are others
who are making people do squats and
push-ups just embarrassing things we
thought like
wait what did that guy do wrong he's
just out during lockdown unnecessarily
and all they do is slap people they're
beating people with sticks everybody and
they think this is the way to contain
this sure and then others are doing like
[ __ ] off dude oh yeah that's the way to
go yeah well in this rather chaotic
you've got over a billion people you
don't have any middle class room you're
gonna have yeah really poor really
stress positions you're gonna have these
cats Jesus Christ this and if you don't
do it I'll be sent to I or in in a
country this big you're gonna have
they've seen eleven deaths that's it you
know big [ __ ] India's yeah they're
doing everything in their power social
that's not a is pretty much the path
Laura it's like New York yeah no hard is
easier because the slums the stuff a
living so but even New York their courts
an outbreak there in New York
everybody's on top of each other yeah
there's no word it it's just not built
like LA spread out so you get social
distance Texas is spread out New York
your honor
[ __ ] yeah Apartments are like Boom
Boom Boom Boom
like yes yes I saw something recently
where I think it was the governor of New
York said that you would have people
find for breaking social distancing
unnecessarily yeah I get it but also you
know 1.3 billion people in India mm-hmm
I think you never trust China right cuz
who knows what information they're
leaking but the people that had it the
success rate out of China now is 93
percent even with the older demo graph
yeah whatever that means to see what
happens all right and you guys already
touched on this but Trump yesterday
extended the social distancing
guidelines until the end of April and
he's hopeful that by the beginning of
June everything everything should be
fine wasn't there something said talking
about the hotter
he's hoping recovering by June what
about Mary
yiii we're not sure if we're locked down
all of April I bet by May work starting
to trickle in then June business is
a-boomin we hope we can only hope enough
statistics I think it'd be quarantine
longer than China
I don't know 60 days there were 60 days
it's a long time how am i we've been
quarantined so far 2 weeks 2 weeks then
it seems like it's easily as forever oh
by the end of Abe I'm telling you I'm
Tony man society's not gonna put up with
it there's already pushed back oh yeah
it's already pushed back because I feel
like a rebel when I go on a hike yeah
people people the biggest thing is your
your business how much relief are you
gonna give a restaurant that has to pay
around tell me people like once the
masses cadastral stats and like hold up
dude you want to do what for how much
longer and these are the harmony and the
Taking Chances
yeah a 93 percent success rate from
China and 98 percent success rate in the
United States let's take my chances yeah
that's what that's what's happening
that's what's get that's what's gonna
happen though that's gonna that
informations gonna start circulating
once it got out that AIDS was not was a
discriminatory disease in terms of it
having regular heterosexual sex was so
low risk so low risk that in fact they
don't even know if you can get it that
way when a man has sex with a woman if
you are of European it's very different
in Africa but once they figured out that
if you survived the bubonic ways you had
a you had a certain generic variation
genetic variation that allowed you to be
resistance aids into a - through
traditional sex regular sex people show
me both things stop using condoms people
were like if you're telling me it's a
straight disease in in the people I know
show me the numbers show me the money
let's ROM at and and it didn't it didn't
happen you know so that that's kind of
what happens you know I I think people
kind of pay attention to those Greeks
even steroids even like you know
testosterone use when you hear people
say well people die and get cancer from
human growth and stuff it's like the
church well show me the bodies we're the
body's people been using this [ __ ] for a
long
and time the the I don't know if you
died earlier but but it means the style
I beg to differ
again I was that sky man you off snaps
off steroids it's like they're not
terrible look that in stats with CT not
terrible right
the majority of football plays majority
of fighters like well that's the number
first show that's you would know more
about this but like if you look at the
if you take the large aggregate number
of NFL players NFL players yeah I don't
know what the percentage is but there
are people that have issues but we're
sure there's outliers yeah but it's not
like everybody know we don't need to
shut down youth football and all that
stuff Lola Cator Hernandez hate so you'd
be the [ __ ] no matter what yeah it's
not the football that did it yeah yeah
so yeah I think you're right to be a
stats guy you got to look at big numbers
you know what else you have a measured
response a measured response I don't
know I don't know right now I'm gonna
say I don't know we don't know a lot and
the one thing I noticed that everybody
talks about when he had the extra time
is there's a lot of I don't I don't know
yeah you know you're like no you know
yeah so I'm not even that I record like
25 million Americans are gonna die
people that wrote that article that
created this whole pandemic went we were
off I think in that are the people that
wrote that that started all this crazy
rat she off we didn't we didn't realize
you guys were gonna quarantine and stuff
like that it's actually way less it's
gonna be way less than that yeah that's
our fault the the news doesn't report
any about she doctor foul she said the
worst-case scenario would be 200,000
people but that's worse worse worst case
scenario so it'll private I see her this
that's a h1n1 a sitting that all this
stuff yeah I mean that killed a lot of
SARS a lot right a lot more so far so
yeah we'll see this shit's about the P
this has been a very weird and
interesting reaction like why why is
this particular virus cuz it's brand new
we don't have a vaccine for it although
the z-pak mixed with that hydro stuff
supposed to be helping yeah hydroxy
sorrow it's called hydroxychloroquine
ein your boy has them really and what
Dad that really helps that yeah in the
cases that's the the success of that so
it's been crazy all right what else gets
in good
while you guys are talking about
different numbers so this is just from
barstool they said that this guy Bill
Mitchell diarrhea diarrhea it does kill
1.8 million people a year
that's no mind area that's because what
it does it dehydrates you so that's a
collar and us caller ID hide so here's
this bill Mitchell says you know what
magic is when the media convinced us a
pandemic which has killed 31,000 people
is more dangerous that the one that
killed five hundred seventy five
thousand people h1n1 and remember
remember Obama did say we have a
pandemic but no one even was like I my
risk of dying from Cove in nineteen is
point to if I'm infected by my chance of
being affected maybe fifteen percent
that puts my chance of dying from Kovac
at 0.03 percent my chance of poverty is
100 cent if we let America's economy
collapse as we cut tower and fear I'll
take my chances covered 19 yeah I
understand what I me too
diarrhea kills 1.8 million people a year
1.8 million all caps where's my diarrhea
check where's my daughter
I mean he's making points that all of us
have to be talking about man you you who
is deciding but note but no one brings
us up like the news doesn't even they
won't even they won't even touch now
they want which is what it's like x they
they are losing their credit bill
alright I like when they're like oh can
you believe America has overtaken Italy
in more cases corona pandemic freaked
out ik hold on you know many more people
we have than Italy if you look at the
numbers of percentages we have lack idea
of as far as and you gotta marry you
don't know who you are actually have it
when you when you do lease it when you
make yeah when you do you know say this
percentage that's of the people that get
tested there could be many moral habit
who don't even know it or exhibit very
mild symptoms so I just think I do think
that the end of April is appropriate I
do think that the conversation has to be
after that we have to go till the end of
April I'm gonna bust everybody's I'm
already buzzing to move to Hawaii I'll
tell you what about you and I as comics
I don't know when we're gonna be
performing for blood oh I know when June
you think so June clubs July come out
July yep July is gonna be booming August
September October November December is
gonna be lit it's [ __ ] you think sounds
I guarantee it
I think June starts trick elating that
but theaters are different theaters when
tied in 1500 people are more people
gonna be a little freaked out still so
if you're a theater only comic it's me
little dicey but club comics right now
clubs are gonna hit em cash out two
hundred fifty to four and fifty people
eat five fifty you're fine
Wow clubs gonna be the first thing that
trickling in june/july is gonna be
booming the summers are me booming for
comics men all right summer 2020 is
gonna be wild when everyone's off of
quarantine we all because because yeah
because when the hot weather I guess
helps with kovat but I do think also
what's gonna happen is more even thing
hey go ha look at these stats who's
actually dying that's what I'm saying
you know well I guess at the end of
April we're gonna see the massive spike
right no two weeks in a week or two you
need a spike and then I think once they
realize the deaths aren't up to h1n1 it
was like we gotta chill out everybody I
know but look at how the media let's
let's just read let me read you some
some of how the media looks at this [ __ ]
I don't know why anyone watches news
from steals nation for a longer shutdown
after our experts warn virus could kill
200,000 in the u.s. that whom nurses die
doctors fall sick and panic rises on
virus frontlines New York Times but they
have to what else are they gonna report
if they go hey actually the numbers are
more like this no one's clicking on them
these people want this panic they want
you do want a reason why they're falling
because the media and politicians have a
bigger voice than do reasonable people
it's great I made they make money so I
mean it's it's scary the the fright that
they put into society for us to shut
down like this is the way this is the
Pentek is being this sweep through New
York City's Medical ranks and anxiety is
growing among normally dispassionate
medical professionals I don't agree you
know iesous is exploding you know [ __ ]
off with your words no but that's what
they that's what they sound like but
it's like it's no different than MMA
media where it's like john jones [ __ ]
it you know it's just like all this
negativity gets clicks that's what they
want you look at any TMZ any of that
stuff you know I mean that's exactly
what it is you
he's no different when you're a news
organization and you are beholden to
your ratings then that's what it is it's
real tough Inlet [ __ ] what else yeah all
right this is a sort of going Varla
it's this guy proposing to his girl and
it's the reaction of the players but
then if you go through the comments
people that'll Kisan something off if I
was [ __ ] her after get out do your
asses boom do that she's chords is he in
high school now I think it's high school
too young you're too young a [ __ ] up
dude although that mast is really good
too young
good guys are that's good very small
college ID
I hope it's college but look at that
booty everyone was talking about her
booty how can you not I know it's really
particularly marry her to get an angle
there's no reason not to marry her
that's it that's a also too young yeah
yeah - you little - yeah that's not how
the quarantine you know some people do
it does I'm gonna quarantine don't for
you but some people do it they get
married and they're good so I don't know
many well my parents got married 24
that's what they did back it's a lot of
part of the countries they still can't
get your parents they get young though
but here's the thing now divorce rates
56 percent so it's like 56 it's hi
Brendon what I've got a problem
no no chin drank this yeah wait Jen okay
now my teeth you see the video chin did
of Papa Tiger King Tiger Tiger King Oh
take a [ __ ] hit it you guys a couple
of alcoholics huh or just like a very
good time dude in this corona [ __ ]
delicious you sure you want to see this
yeah yeah alright what's the other video
posted see this um just how to play
everyone's ask me how I played it I just
played it by ear so I just taught them
all this she was really singing this
this is from the tyre King you know
that's not one of the songs that he does
[Music]
is losing all the crowds into burning
that came
[Music]
and the cat starts our cats t-shirt
touch your lower back
[Music]
okay
because you know
I'll be great for fine kid 3d - is give
the right to massage in another video
oh yeah Brian dressed up like tiger cats
all Snow Leopard a little cloud leopard
it's really nice cool thank you
really really good what was the other
video had on their chin it's getting a
lot of views this one like jiggle is
this that what is this one the day in
the life of Oh mine yeah can I see this
sure it's just a little like a straight
hair it's usually at a dead stop is free
flowing like crazy right now this is my
apartment I won't show you too much that
Prius you have a Prius now yeah he's
always had a free longest time scrap
cars to the snow 45k room or the belt
studio I'm secure and format okay
[Music]
I love Kevin avocado is adorable the
best there's Brian here this Jimbo token
car I just wish it was easier to
intercept
[Music]
heading back up she will show us your
girl chin I mean not sure dude skyline
six three seven seven watching dick
whatever it's great that cool yeah
thanks you want one more crying eventing
yeah yeah this is a really good one this
is this guy's a hero
Oh Kanan Bauer Han dude how weird is
that we're looking at bikes and now
they're up there oh I know do you're
listening they're definitely looking
Annandale everybody school wrestling
champions fifteen stop kidnapping of
three children by penicillin play dry
the sixteen-year-old but he said to nap
three to sixteen a six to two hundred
eighty-five pounds so here's the footage
so here what happened was a woman got
dropped off with the autograph a
Greyhound bus station she had three kids
with her and then some random guy 2000
guy tried to steal one of the kids and
there they're like you know different
people trying to help her out
they couldn't really stop him he was
punching his way out I'll play the video
and then this guy comes over he was
filling up gas at the gas station nearby
saw the commotion drove by and he just
took this dude down a badass let me see
this scumbag let me see the wait for
this add a stolen right now I'm trying
to my kid if you talk to me not to kill
you know I mean what would happen I
should die anybody who does this to
children should die I'm serious although
you can put the [ __ ] so right now I'll
show you the guy take a child yeah he
tried to take the child and then you
started punching the woman and they know
the people that are trying to help her
so then with me she got her kids right
now they're running into this store and
this guy is the one that's trying to
take him that kid right there they've
got a Hadiya punching and punching
everyone he's punching them all yes and
what look see they're just it's
Samaritan yes I think it might be a
mental thing yeah of course or maybe
someone who wants to steal kitty stop a
bad person I think we do doesn't matter
he should die I agree so this guy's
trying not to let him let him in then
then he just punches this dude holy [ __ ]
man
well we've this piece of [ __ ] yep fight
him he's crazy definitely crazy I do
anything
you can't fight yeah yeah run flocks
them in there which is terrible
and then this guy that's cannon in the
green see he's going on [ __ ] going on
yeah and then it goes boom right after
huh really double or you you'll see lit
you'll see the guy on the ground here
throw him on the ground well that's the
biggest teenager cat a 16 year old doing
this like your skin is 285 what a brave
dude yeah oh then the mom gets her head
yeah [ __ ] yeah hell yeah kick him in the
face
so cannon holds him down to the police
arrived what do the police do with this
guy he's in jail for sure I know but
you're like him so check it out he's not
that damn it you don't go for that long
you know so police arrived Kanaan's
holding the guy down and then you'll see
the mom she no she just gives him a big
hug because he essentially saved
enormous like a hero
what a [ __ ] stunt badass that's
looking at pictures of it look at that
badass on the Left I know
16 years old wow what a stud but dudes
like this need to die agree there is
what this family dude see does he have a
scholarship so where do we know I hope
so I don't know my massive man yeah one
for the good guys
mm-hmm reminds me of the Rockwood photo
of the revenue 16 this sounds sick to me
but with a guy like that you like if I
really kill her I would say hey just
break his neck just so he never can know
something like paralyzed that [ __ ]
I mean for real yeah that's it you know
it's like the war human like tonight go
I'll put him in a [ __ ] wheelchair
give an ankle lock Britain [ __ ]
ripped both the 10000 go [ __ ] neck
like just a piece of [ __ ] yeah that's
him that's the piece of [ __ ] 22 year old
doesn't make it you need to have that
neck just popped a little scary man well
it's the scary it's not the worst and I
I think it's always really important to
be ready for whatever man I'm sorry you
got to be ready I'm a helicopter parent
I'm [ __ ] it's so scary what else you
got what some more you know it's not a
nun that piece of [ __ ] see that kid was
a girl straight look at her boy before I
go there
Wow this is a the tiger kings Jeff I
don't I didn't watch the series but that
guy Jeff I guess I ain't such a good guy
either I don't think okay that guy's got
a lot of Jeff Lowe's a piece of [ __ ] Wow
he's got his yes so this is about the
nanny so he's talking about the nanny
here and that's I guess that's his wife
yeah and that's her it's Magnus
those kind of guys find those girls
shake out that nanny yeah look you learn
Andy well I mean obviously they all get
down I'm so confused how all these men
are pulling good luck I get it
manipulative Tigers manipulative and if
they work it out they pay her I'm sure
it's part of like yeah it's show
business look at that so what's it
smashing the nanny yet he said wouldn't
you yeah Wow look man she's hot it's but
there's more pictures over there Jesus
Christ
gorgeous animal she was holding out what
does that go back to that animal she was
on that what kind of cat is that that
looks god that's Tiger take your leopard
yeah looks like a leopard an Tiger I
said a liger no no dear you
I think [ __ ] you know she's she's em
she's delicious
that's not your nanny she just happens
to come over and bang you guys and then
and watch your holds the baby but also
watch you thinking yeah but also I give
it you know so this is what we're
looking at earlier this Elizabeth Hurley
talking about her quarantine situation
and then she posted these pictures she
is so hot Auto but here's the other
pictures olders awesome she's older than
I am she's amazing oh man
sometimes you have risk it all for where
that right Elizabeth Hurley one of the
Great's what I would root blast away I
would blast just blast hey I need you to
calm down I know what you do just calm
down okay don't say blast away that just
relax all right I got you okay I got
that you're a little worked up right now
it's it's this [ __ ] Monday and the
[ __ ] rock Monday porn [ __ ] rock Monday's
are always he might a little crazy and
we come in a little prickly coming a
little hot quarantine Monday that's it
we've been cooped up since last
Wednesday we come in hot so nice a blast
way I mean I underst
it's only gonna get worse two more weeks
of this to come on for bids oh [ __ ]
we're not even in April yet what's the
date which 3:30 all right I know yeah we
got a month one whole month and that's
just a nip it in the butt you know and
then we'll be sailing after that sailing
you mean yeah are you guys enjoying your
at least er your delivery your food
deliveries and needing a home I go and
get food yeah so I mean it's kind of fun
sometimes
well for all our for all our 80 plus
your old listeners please take care
yep yeah good luck out there take care
quarantined if you're over 80 list the
spot yeah good luck I have a friend
who's under 50
outstanding health conditions won't
grass back in the work field my buddy
Jack Betts who's let me do 90 years old
he's locked down at 90 and I got a he
said if you need anything I'll bring you
something but now I'm afraid to even
touch when he's 90 so he should be
worried about allergies look he's a book
in your 90 a steel horse he'll probably
laugh and caranas he's he's been smoking
for his whole life exactly as Miami
allergies is gonna [ __ ] an old person
you know Rip Taylor you know my you know
my dad hasn't left his house in two
weeks
your dad's true yeah I got a real on
dude
I sent my video me junior seasick what
are you doing how can you be out like
what are you doing he's a rule follower
no he's older so you know he's only 60
yeah you gotta be careful done it
quarantine kids that's it quarantine
kids quarantine kids you talk a lot
about [ __ ] it 3d here we six feet apart
we're 6 feet apart right here right yeah
this is that's 2 feet right no yeah your
mouth of my mouth are 6 feet apart no
way
yes sir no way 100% we're 6 feet away
it's one no measuring tape I do watch
this I hope I do how tall are you cat
I'm like 5 1 5 2 is that mean tell me
cat could lay down here I'm saying we're
6 feet apart
not cat could lay down and touch both of
it mouth sound I think you're gonna be
surprised
mouth-to-mouth no we're not no just dude
nearest body part no that one no mater
spotty part now because you're here I'm
saying ma'am you get our knees our body
parts not important what's matter just
mouth to mouth mouth to mouth so to say
how much feet what's that closest thing
that mark and we got a computer Jim's
right there there what is that it's five
not six do not six almost it's not not
what were that dude violating curfew
better hope you don't get warranty fever
than a coffee vers the big thing or give
me a date uh guys I'll be nowhere now
say knees next week everybody Ida
Caswell my flights from my hotel also we
released new merch surf-and-turf I call
that's right good call we have fake
boyhood ease restock those get sold out
big boy hoodies restocked we got sweet
tart intern a city's teas and then Surf
& Turf Fight Club Oh sir shop senator
let me medium hey dum-dum J doesn't do
the merch anymore oh hell I'm gonna side
with killer McGrath chick boys my
favorite I wear it all the time and I
wear a t-shirt all the time you I do I
want to make sick boy for kids god I'd
be so pleased such a good idea and so
many people would buy ya know I'll guess
reports a surf-and-turf Fight Club
I love the blue don't T FATCA calm for a
surf-and-turf thick boy sweet tart wow
that's it man
alright guys until next time say they
say yeah this the finala kid we're out